voilà c'était voyage en barbarie un
document exceptionnel auquel vous ne
manquerez pas de réagir j'en suis sûr
sur les réseaux sociaux je vous rappelle
notre adresse hashtag docu débat c'est
un documentaire que nous devons à deux
femmes
cécile allegra bonsoir et delphine
deloget merci d'être là toutes les deux
pour débattre aussi avec nos jean
françois dubost bienvenus vous êtes
responsable du programme personnes
déracinées d'amnesty international et
puis vous fabiano et roux vous êtes
cinéaste chercheuse au cnrs et
spécialiste de la question des réfugiés
alors tellement de questions se posent
quand on vient de voir un tel
documentaire cécile allegra delphine
deloget comment vous avez eu d'abord
connaissance de ce problème alors d'agir
à l'origine c'est vrai que moi je
connaissais les erythréens pour voir
faire un documentaire à calais j'étais
resté ami avec eux est déjà en 2011 il
m'en avait parlé mais j'avais réduit un
peu cette histoire a une histoire de
passeurs qui tournaient mal et quelques
années plus tard enfin du coup en 2011
l'année dernière
je suis allé rencontrer meron parce que
je prépare effectivement avec cécile un
documentaire plutôt sur l'erythrée et je
les ai vus pendu comme ça au téléphone
sans arrêt au sida avec des appels qui
venait du sinaï et j'ai compris ce qui
se passait effectivement et là j'en ai
reparlé à cécile et d'un seul coup on a
laissé tomber le projet sur l'erythrée
pour un temps ouais pour se consacrer
essentiellement à ce problème ce dernier
paraissait extrêmement urgent c'est vrai
qu'en étant d'origine italienne en
italie on a beaucoup d'erythréens dans
les âmes du réfugié à paris réfugiée en
italie et lampedusa
oui et donc moi je connaissais le
problème des erythréens par là le côté
italien
je savais qu'ils étaient blessés dans
leur chair je savais pas à quel point et
c'est à ce moment là qu'on s'est
rencontré sur cette question et prendre
a commencé à vouloir savoir justement
pourquoi ils arrivaient dans cet état là
comment vous êtes entré en contact avec
ces jeunes hommes que l'on entend ça a
été très long
il ya une partie européenne et une
partie au caire la partie en europe a
été a été très complexe parce que là
communautaire et rennes est une
communauté fermée
méfiante paranoïaque parce qu'ils sont
persécutés or les frontières par des
représentants du régime daffé war kids
issaias afeworki et donc à juste titre
ils sont méfiants donc pour gagner leur
confiance il a fallu beaucoup de temps
on a été à londres on a été à rome
on a été en suède à stockholm on a
rencontré les principaux leaders de la
communauté ça a été un travail de fourmi
il a fallu se faire accepter et ensuite
il ya eu le pendant du caire et une
galerie nom et au caire et donc au caire
effectivement de départ c'est très
compliqué déjà de tourner au caire
en temps normal donc des erythréens qui
n'ont pas de papiers au caire qui ont
été torturés c'était encore une autre
histoire
donc comme vient de le dire cécile qui
en plus une peur à la fois du
gouvernement mais en plus cette peur
d'être repris à nouveau c'est à dire
qu'il faut vraiment comprendre que c'est
des gens qui sont ces packs un trauma
c'est qu'ils ont aussi cette peur d'être
kidnappé de nouveau donc à la fois de 10
rencontrés dans un premier temps on a
été trois fois trois ou quatre fois
enfin trois fois je monte un peu perdue
parce que ça a été
et puis on ne verra sans doute plus tard
mais ils sont pas forcément sécurité en
est justement non sont ils savent
vraiment ils sont vraiment laissés pour
compte aussi là-bas en au caire donc ils
sont perdus abandonnés
donc qu'ils ont quand même des dn1 par
par des associations qui travaillent un
pinceau en souterrain parce que voilà le
gouvernement nie aussi un peu le
problème donc il faut pas faire trop de
bruit
en parlant de ces réfugiés donc ils sont
quand même un sentiment un peu
d'abandons donc arrivé avec une caméra
c'est quand même assez assez compliqué
et je veux pas oublier que même au car
ils sont en danger c'est à dire qu' à
l'instant où ils montrent leur visage où
on met un nom sur un parcours très
risqué leur vie
est-ce que ce qu'il faut rappeler c'est
qu'une partie de ces réfugiés qui ont un
vécu la torture sont emprisonnés
directement en fait en egypte sous
prétexte de ne pas avoir d'autorisation
d'entrer seul d'entrée sur le territoire
donc ça pose des questions sur
lesquelles on viendra je voudrais qu'on
parle du personnage de mayronnes qui est
central dans toute cette question du
résumé nous parce que c'est ces riches
d'où elle vient et ce qu'elle fait
exactement et qu'elle ambiguïté que ça
peut poser mais c'est une journaliste en
fait c'est une militante à l'origine une
journaliste militante qui s'est trouvée
par le hasard de son parcours de
journaliste a animé une émission de
radio où des personnes de la diaspora
érythréenne venez raconter un petit peu
leur parcours de vie et à partir de là
partir de 2009
en décembre 2001
elle a commencé à recevoir des appels en
direct du sinaï de gens qui se faisaient
torturé et c'est là que son militantisme
a basculé en fait parce que jean simple
animatrice radio elle est devenue la
référente pour les pour les personnes
qui étaient séquestrés dans le sinaï est
en fait un point de sortie
une personne dont on se repasse le
numéro parce qu'on savait qu'elle
pourrait être à l'autre bout du fil et
j'ai justement les les téléphones ils
viennent d'où en fait parce que quand on
la voit pendu au téléphone et qu'on
entend ces personnes qui vivent ce
cauchemar on se dit mais d'où vient
téléphone ils l'ont volé ils sont cachés
non parce qu'en fait c'est le jeu du
téléphone fait partie de l'usagé de la
torture de toute façon donc le fait
qu'ils aient un téléphone effectivement
ça peut paraître étrange mais ça fait
partie de d'un système de torture mis en
place étaient les airs sionnel c'est à
dire que c'est une torture en direct
donc le téléphone il est le haut parleur
à chaque torture et branché il appelle
les familles donc mais ron l
effectivement quand comme le dit cécile
elle a un peu aussi basculé dans le sens
où elle a voulu confier des preuves donc
enregistrer ces témoignages là et cette
torture donc les krills et au moment où
la torture se passe donc les familles
appelle aussi un peu mais ron à la
rescousse en dix ans et c'est d'être en
contact avec eux pour les réconforter
2 effectivement c'est collecter de
l'argent via la radio donc et l'intérêt
de collecter l'argent pour la radio
c'est intéressent évidemment les
tortionnaires donc meron fait c'est là
on rejoint le statut un peu ambiguë est
aussi un maillon de tout ce système on
va on va là la réécouter meron tout de
suite pour un documentaire britannique
aux évidences et gainsbourg david
beckham causeway raft textile c'est pas
mal à y répondre aux personnes physiques
htc watch wade voulait réagir oui
absolument mais on est là elle a
enregistré plus de 1500 appels
c'est un corpus de preuves complètement
exceptionnel c'est grâce à sa réactivité
qu'on a pu avoir autant de traces de
gens passaient par sinaï dans ses 1500
appels et là qui sont décédés et c'est
la seule trace qu'ils ont pu laisser de
leur passage par le sinaï il y en a qui
ont survécu qui sont au caire et c'est
la seule trace qu'on aime qui prouve
qu'ils sont passés par le sénat il y en
a qui ont survécu qui sont en europe et
ça permet de le re lol lors leur donner
l'accès au statut de réfugié plus
rapidement donc le trait de mayronnes
est fondamentale
jouerez-vous réaction est ce
documentaire fabiano
je trouve que c'est vraiment un très
beau documentaire vraiment intéressant
aussi bien sur la forme que sur le fond
sur la forme je trouve l'écriture
visuelle intéressante parce que les
paysages ses télescopes qui sont un peu
la métaphore de des situations de
torture j'ai bien aimé le passage par
exemple de la neige les premiers plans
sur la neige
à
après on passe d'un désert de neige un
désert de sable et donc la manière dont
le film joue avec les situations me
paraît fort intéressante
je trouve qu'il ya même de la poésie
c'est à dire que même dans cette horreur
la manière dont on joue avec les
paysages à une espèce de poésie je
trouve le montage intéressant ça a été
fait de manière intelligente et sensible
pour moi oui et avec un certain courage
alors maintenant sur le fond et sur
l'éthique
là j'ai quand même des interrogations
j'ai fait beaucoup de films sur les
réfugiés et je n'ai jamais eu le courage
peut-être que je n'ai jamais eu le
courage de deux de photographier ou de
d'avoir une caméra face à une blessure
j'ai faim j'ai fait par exemple un flip
sur sur les réfugiés du darfour en
egypte et je me suis interdit peut-être
parce que je ne savais pas l'écrire
visuellement
j'ai toujours utilisé la métaphore et en
regardant ce film je me suis dit elles
sont allées très loin c'est bien ça
n'est pas une critique mais je me pose
des questions c'est quand même mon rôle
de chercheur que de poser des questions
et je me suis dit mais pourquoi montrer
l'horreur pourquoi ce gros plan à la 43e
minute sur ses moignons demain mais moi
et je vais vous dire moi ce plan est mal
il m'a beaucoup frappé aussi et je pense
que c'est très rare de voir ces images
et qu'il faut les voir parce que je
pense que ce sont des situations qui
sont inimaginables
exactement alors si on peut répondre à
chaque évêché la firme alexion on débat
mais alors mais sur ce point si vous
voulez réagir et moi j'étais une chose à
dire et je pense que delphine a là aussi
son point de vue là dessus c'est que la
question de raconter la torture a été au
centre de nos interrogations on en a
débattu un nombre de fois à ses
incalculables
parce que justement et je pense que vous
l'avez bien remarquée dans le film on
n'est pas focalisé sur montrer l'horreur
simplement au bout d'un moment au bout
de la
43e minute où on en parle eh bien je
pense que à ce moment là la montre et
permettent deux choses la première chose
c'est de comprendre jusqu'où yvan parce
que c'est réellement inédits qu'ils
aillent aussi loin
la deuxième chose c'est quand même de
mettre un nom sur un parcours avec une
blessure et en fait ça constituent un
corpus de preuves
voilà ça c'est mon ma réponse à cette
question et je pense que delfim à et à
sa vision qui est importante parce que
elle a soigné la mise en image gens
pensent que parce que je trouve que
c'est finement abordé c'est dire qu'on a
tout le temps de s'imprégner de ces
horribles témoignages et simplement à la
fin qu'on a déjà fait presque tout le
parcours dans l'horreur que on a une
réalité qui s'impose et c'est assez
important je pense quoi sinon ça peut
rester dans l'ordre des mots et ça reste
assez d'ailleurs inimaginable or là ça
rend tout à fait imaginer ce qu'il se
passe après ce que moi ce que me m'a
fait sentir cette ce documentaire c'est
une immense tristesse parce qu'en fait
c'est une phase au rythme de leur
parcours mais c'est pas la seule
il en a déjà eu une version manga et
venir on est dans un style très
simplement après pour pouvoir et tenter
de rejoindre les européennes on verra
certainement et delphine alors dit
mais il ya quand même un problème c'est
que heureusement ces images de blessures
et de blessures mais immonde horrible
arrive qu à la 43e minute et pas au
début c'est pour ça que je trouve que le
montage est très fin je fais beaucoup de
montage je trouve que ça arrive au bon
moment
mais alors qu'est-ce qui vous qu'est-ce
qui vous avez l'air de mai alors que
vous titille alors c'est ce qui ce qui
me gêne c'est quand même lorsqu'il se
dénude lorsqu'il montre le torse et
lorsqu'on voit les blessures est-ce que
sur ces scènes là vous n'êtes pas poser
des questions des questions
fondamentales
est-ce qu'il n'y a pas des gens est-ce
qu'il ya pas des téléspectateurs qui
vont penser que tous les bédouins sont
des bourreaux est-ce qu'il veut pas y
avoir d raku en est justement là pour
pouvoir éclaircir les points et c'est
savoir si tous les bédouins sont sont
des tortionnaires se pense pas que ce
soit en montrant les blessures qui est
comprise raccourci là par contre ça
c'est une autre question
le fait de montrer les blessures
évidemment comme dit cécile c'est une
question fondamentale le coeur du
travail de comment raconte la torture
alors normalement d'un parti j'ai juste
effectivement après ça fait peut-être la
synthèse de ce qui s'est dit c'est qu'à
un moment donné faut savoir de quoi on
parle
non parce que c'est des mots nous mêmes
on n'a pas mesuré mois comme on
ad'ailleurs 2011
j'ai pas voulu voir ouais après meron je
me suis dit c'est cécile qui m'a dit tu
sais que ça va être un film sur la
torture et d'un seul coup je me suis dit
mais ben oui ça va être un film sur la
torture je l'avais presque pas formulé
comme ça parce que parce que ça fait
peur et oui c'est vrai tu as cru et la
torture
c'est ça c'est les mains de philémon et
un moment donné si vous regardez bien
c'est pas nous qui lui demandant d'
enlever ses gants c'est qu'ils visitent
vous voulez je peux les voulais montrer
et tout le long du film effectivement ça
a été un choix de dire on veut pas je
veux pas focaliser aux cadres on voulait
pas du skate peut-être aussi par des
mois je vous coupe et c'est peut-être
aussi pour lui une des rares profs qui
lui reste à lui de prouver qu'il ne
manque pas d'ailleurs un nouveau témoin
un moment dit de toute façon on n'est
pas là pour dire notre ressenti parce
que personne ne peut comprendre on la
seule chose qu'on peut faire c'est dire
les faits il faut qu'on il faut quand
même bien comprendre que pendant tout ce
temps c'est à dire ce trafic a commencé
à partir de 2008 s'est aggravée au
tournant 2009 2010 2012 a été une année
épouvantable d'abattage
il ya eu des milliers de morts et vous
vous avez des gens qui sortent de là
qu'ils ne peuvent pas parler parce
qu'ils savent qu'ils vont être
pourchassés par des suppôts du régime
qui sont blessés dans leur chair mais
qui peuvent pas le forcément le montrer
aux autorités qui les prennent en charge
filmant quand il est allé témoigner
devant l'union européenne il a fait le
choix de témoigner à visage masqué on ne
voyait que ses mains il n'existait que
par ses mains et le choix de nous
montrer ses mains et un visage c'était
pour nous dire je m'appelle film je suis
ses mains je suis un parcours je suis
une personnalité et je vous parle à
visage découvert et c'est mon choix de
le faire maintenant
alors avançons dans ce débat nous
question une des premières questions qui
se posent quand quand on regarde le de
commentaires on se dit mais pourquoi
c'est à vitré pourquoi eux précisément
des réfugiés y en a beaucoup dans le
monde
alors ce qu'on peut expliquer d'abord
c'est que l'erythrée c'est une dictature
c'est un tout petit pays mais sans doute
la pire dictature d'afrique bah oui
c'est la pire dictature rassemblement
depuis depuis 20 ans depuis la
dépendance annoncé un catalogue de
violations que nous amnistie
internationale ne cesse de dénoncer
régulièrement chaque fois que c'est
possible et notamment auprès des
nations-unies qui en ont plus ou moins
conscience mais c'est tout ce qu'il ya
de pire en termes de violations des
droits humains
ça touche à peu près toutes les
catégories de la population toutes les
couches de population évidemment les
journalistes évidemment les personnes
qui sont engagées politiquement mais
également aussi tout un chacun parce que
le service militaire est un moyen de
pression et de contraindre un gâteau
nation obligatoire de 18 à 40 ans avec
une période jusqu'à 50 ans en réalité
limitée à 12 18 mois est en fait de
façon totalement a défini six garçons et
ça se transforme en travail forcé et la
moindre le moindre problème se
transforme en séance de torture le viol
de deux viols de de détention dans des
conteneurs en plein soleil de positions
douloureuses en plein soleil dans le
désert face et inimaginables et ces
personnes bonne partie des réfugiés
érythréens fui ce service militaire
envie de toi c'est à dire
qu'effectivement canton quand on y
regarde de plus près on s'aperçoit que
c'est une dictature qui pratiquent des
tortures qu'ils ne vont peut-être pas
aussi loin encore dans l'horreur que les
maisons de danton mais on n'est quand
même pas loin parce que on laisse par
exemple des gens attachés en plein
soleil se faire dévorer par les insectes
etc
on viole les fils avaient partie de la
la formation du service militaire en
gros c'est une prison à ciel ouvert
en quelque sorte oui en plus il est
dangereux potentiellement dangereux de
partir du pays d'abord parce qu'on va
être considérés comme traîtres
appartement on est sorti sans
autorisation en plus parce que il ya un
ordre qui reste formel qui a été
appliquée à une époque de tirer à vue
sur les personnes qui quittent le
territoire mérite cet ordre reste encore
en vigueur
et si les personnes sont renvoyées comme
cela arrive du soudan au des gîtes ou
parfois pays européens en erythrée là
c'est la même chose disparitions forcées
détentions au secret tortures mauvais
traitements donc une pression de tous
les côtés est ce que l'expression
gagnent culture dont on parle
de là vient alors oui moi j'ai enfin
j'ai démontré que cette gueule tu gagnes
culturel est bien plus ancien c'est
quelque chose qui existe déjà pendant la
période de la colonisation italienne ait
eu des travaux sur la colonisation
italienne plusieurs plusieurs thèses qui
ont été soutenues qui démontre que les
italiens pour l'erythrée avait un projet
c'est de faire de l'erythrée le
réservoir de leurs troupes et de leurs
soldats d'ailleurs ils ont eu de
nombreux supplétifs qu'on appelait les
ascari et c'est ascari érythréens ont
formé les gros des troupes coloniales
italienne ils ont participé à la guerre
de libye donc c'était vraiment les
gardes-chiourme de l' empire et donc il
existe à partir du moment coloniale
italienne
une gueule une bonne culture en erythrée
qui a été reprise par les pls par le
front de libération erythréens et donc
il faut comprendre que c'est un pays qui
est extrêmement militarisé c'est pas
simplement une armée c'est une bonne
culte c'est la plus grande armée
d'afrique c'est l'un des plus petits
pays d'afrique mais c'est la plus grande
armée d'afrique c'est juste oui à peu
près 150 mille même temps avec un
service obligatoire de 17 à 50 ans donc
en fait quand les erythréens d'ailleurs
fui vers la frontière
l' erreur à ne pas commettre c'est de ne
pas laisser son arme parce que là on est
sûr de se faire pourchasser et tous les
évadés d'erythrée sache bien que
il faut laisser larmes avec toutes les
balles à l'intérieur pour passer la
frontière
donc le gros de ces réfugiés sont des
déserteurs de l'armée il faut bien le
savoir aussi bien filles que garçons ils
ont subi des horreurs en erythrée ils
partent pour un mieux vivre parce qu'ils
ne se reconnaissent plus dans cette
dictature il souvent ils sont fussent de
fighters
c'est à dire de de combat combattants
libérer le pays dans les années dans les
années 90 et souvent leur grand-père
étaient eux mêmes askari c'est à dire 1
ayant fait des des recherches sur les
cycles les supplétifs de l'armée
italienne et les fighters des années 90
il ya une espèce de filiation et donc on
est quand même dans une bonne culture
c'est à dire que le héros la figure
héroïque de la culture et érythréenne
contemporaine
c'est là où le 20e siècle c'est le
fighters qu'elle et quels sont les
soutiens de ce régime
aujourd'hui j'ai lu dans un article du
monde
mais 2013 que le qatar le financer en
partie dans l'union européenne qui
alliant alors qu'elle a soutenu puis
jusqu'en 2011 150 millions d'euros de
dollars je ne sais pas exactement
absolument oui ce que d'ailleurs les
résistants avaient très hâte et de
l'aide au développement a précédemment
mais c'est vrai que c'est vrai que du
coup pour pour les pour les pour les
résistants érythréens cela constitue une
sorte de chèque en blanc au régime des
régimes comme ça quand on leur donne 150
millions d'euros
c'est quoi la contrepartie sans une
forme de stabilité et kaunas dans l'aide
au développement je suppose que l'idée
c'est de tenter de stabiliser pacifier
réduire les problèmes dans le pays en
les prenant par un autre biais que
attaquer frontalement la question des
droits humains mais dans le cas de
l'erythrée c'est quand même tellement
flagrant est ignoble et répondu à grande
échelle que c'est un peu peine perdue me
semble-t-il
il faut aussi noter que l'erythrée vit
en permanence dans le en tout cas on
entretient ce climat de peur d'être
attaqués d'être en conflit avec ses
voisins djibouti l'ethiopie et il ya un
différend frontalier qui peut expliquer
pour partie cette militarisation et ce
maintien l'as le différend frontalier
entre l'éthiopie l'érythrée n'est
toujours pas réglé le finalement la
communauté arsenal met pas trop de
pression dessus ça pourrait être un
moyen de faire baisser la pression qu'il
faut expliquer aux téléspectateurs c'est
que l'erythrée a obtenu son indépendance
de l'ethiopie en 1993 mais finalement
c'est assez récent et que depuis cette
indépendance quelque part on se prépare
à nouveau à une guerre en fait ils ont
connu une guerre de deux ans 98 qui
s'est terminée en 2000 avec les accords
d'alger
mais depuis 2000 il ya sans cesse des
conflits de frontières
les erythréens qui fuit on parle de 3 à
4000 par mois par mois ce oui ça donne
sur une année parce que ce héros
l'excellence des soins les rayons 6
millions 6 millions c'est des chiffres
de l'ue à n'acheter est donc en fait la
plupart franchissent la frontière avec
le tweet précisé le ministère il lui
arrache sert donc c'est l'office qui
s'occupe des réfugiés qui est rattachée
à l'onu et dans le cr ont pensé le htc
pour les actions en cours et donc ils
sont concernés au premier chef puisque
il s'occupe de deux gros camp de
réfugiés qui sont juste de l'autre côté
de la frontière et rennes qui sont à la
gare avec à salah et c'est vers ces deux
camps que convergent les fuyards et
c'est entre la frontière et rennes et
l'entrée de ces deux camps que à peu
près un tiers des migrants sont enlevés
un autre tir se fait enlever dans les
abords immédiats du camp au moment où
ils sortent pour chercher du bois ou
pour accomplir d'autres tâches du
quotidien donc
effectivement maintenant c'est des
chiffres officiels et ils sont très
alarmants baissé de 7 en constante
augmentation en fait il voulait alors la
deuxième question c'est pourquoi le
sinaï pourquoi ils vont là je voudrais
qu'on réécoute le témoignage de cet
ancien tortionnaire que vous intervenez
dans le documentaire
elles veulent aller au delà
moi je sais pas ce qui se passe delphine
deloget de quelle guerre on parle
vous savez bien ce qui se passe moi je
sais pas bien ce qui se passe c'est que
depuis un an en fait le sinaï est en
état de guerre
mais pas pour du tout les raisons qu'on
aurait espéré
c'est à dire de libérer des otages mais
parce que c'est depuis 2009 aussi à des
campus culot djihadistes terroristes qui
qui pullulent enfin qu'ils ont on va
dire ça comme ça pour résumer et ils ont
eu l'autorisation
donc il faut savoir que le sinaï est une
zone démilitarisée depuis les accords du
camp d'avis depuis 1979 à peu près c'est
ça ce sont plus de cent dix neuf
appareils j'explique aux gens donc le
nord du sinaï en fête a été rétrocédé
par israël à l'egypte
juste en fait au moment de la guerre de
kippour voilà que c'est une zone qui est
complètement désertique où il ne se
passe rien ce n'est pas économiquement à
la hanche aux et lyon classieux à
beaucoup de phénomènes occultes voilà
assez c'est ce qu'ont donc c'est une
terre un peu de laissés pour compte ou
qui ont pris en charge toutes sortes de
trafics et un trafic d'un trafic de
drogue trafics en tous genres
et effectivement depuis 2009 ce trafic
d'êtres humains et c'est une zone qui
non contrôlé une zone voulue tel quel
depuis sur décision effectivement de
l'egypte de l'israël et là avec ces
groupuscules djihadistes qui font un
petit peu peur l'israël a autorisé
effectivement l'egypte a bombardé la
zone
quand on parle des bédouins de qui on
parle ce sont tous ont peint de la tribu
des savoirs cas qui attribue qui est du
nord-est
2 du sinaï donc qui est dans une zone
pratiquement c'est une petite bande à
peu près 15 km qui frontalière de la
bande de gaza qui est aussi un
indicateur de pas mal de choses oui bien
sûr c'est allé loin d'al arich et donc
en fait c'est oui c'est sur la route de
rafah si on voulait donc du coup cette
tribu là dont on voit dans le film un
autre représentant qui est le cheikh
mohamed avoue vidal qui lui libère les
enfin en tout cas essaye de libérer les
détenus dans le sinaï ccc des membres de
cette tribu que c'est l'argent tribu
dans le sinaï qui prennent en charge les
camps de torture mais il faut bien
comprendre que pour eux c'est un
commerce comme un autre ils nous le
disent bien dans le film c'est à dire
que des êtres humains du lait en poudre
il faut il faut qu'ils survivent c'est
une c du trafic en fait c est pas la
notion de l'humanité du tout où deux
personnes certes c'est un trafic comme
un autre c'est parce que c'est un
investissement
tesla rachète qui les revendent
d'ailleurs édité franchement et que ce
qu'on a fait on aurait dû gagner
beaucoup plus alors c'est très important
de comprendre que il avance des sommes
pour les récupérer dans le sinaï et qu'
il y a tout un tout en un maillon enfin
il ya plusieurs maillons sur le sur le
chemin donc vous avez les gardes
frontières du soudan qui prennent leur
part vous avez des gardes des camps de
réfugiés qui permet leur part les garde
frontières soudan egypte qui prennent
leur part à chaque fois que vous passez
la mer rouge il ya des gens qui prennent
leur part quand vous passez un poste de
police dans le sinaï
vous avez des bakchichs qui sont là
c'est donc eux ils prennent en charge
tout ça il débourse ou bien oui mais
alors la question fabienne nos héros ils
sont ciblés donc c'est hériterait ruine
grand panneau sénégal commence parce que
c'est un pays qui est parmi les diplômés
quand on voit l'argent vient dentaire on
voit bien que la plupart parlent un
anglais remarquable ces jeux qui
aujourd'hui parlent un anglais est
remarquable en erythrée ce sont les
étudiants ou des gens qui appartiennent
à des familles qui sont capables de les
envoyer dans des écoles très cher comme
l'école américaine dont les ans ou les
écoles anglo saxon celui qui a les mêmes
les parle un anglais parfait alors je
n'ai pas fini
donc ce qui veut dire que et d'ailleurs
j'ai pu le voir également il ya dix ans
lorsque je faisais des recherches sur
les réfugiés érythréens
ce sont des gens de classes urbaines
pour les trois quarts ce sont des
urbains et ce sont des gens qui viennent
de familles qui ont assez riche et donc
ils ont été ciblés dans les camps avant
d'être qu'il n'avait pas et qui se sait
du tout le cas aujourd'hui je me permets
donc de planer depuis en fait les
premiers ça a été le cas il ya eu un
ciblage et puis maintenant c'est du tout
venant vous avez des gens qui parlent
pas bien l'anglais ça a été un peu un
hasard que nous on trouve aussi des gens
qui s'expriment aussi bien parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de gens qui viennent des
campagnes au contraire est une des
problématiques c'est justement la
déconstruction de toute la la le
bien-être économique de la communauté
érythréenne à l'étranger de par le fait
que toute la communauté elle sollicitait
pour payer les rançons et ça détruit des
dizaines et des dizaines de vies à
l'étranger donc ça concerne plus
uniquement je me permets de préciser les
jeunes urbains
ça concerne maintenant tout le monde de
manière ludique
robel dans le film on parle on parle
d'une femme de 60 ans un moment donné
qui a fait intervenir à lundi le
tortionnaire le dit bien à un moment
donné il cible les erythréens parce
qu'il connaît parfaitement la situation
en erythrée dont keith est à mon avis
aussi on sait parfaitement que ces
personnes continueront tant que le
régime restera celui là continueront de
partir dans continueront d'être
vulnérable continueront d'être à ce
passage où ils se font enlever
continueront d'être dans ce camp de
réfugiés sauf s'ils ont trouvé une
solution au niveau international dont
continueront de constituer un vivier et
le côté ce ne sont que des produits en
fait cette propre de la traite des êtres
humains quelle que soit la forme qu'elle
prend hélas à la forme la plus horrible
les personnes les personnes en plus ne
se sentent pas tortionnaires mais on
al'impression de traiter de la
marchandise et c'est bien ça la traite
enfin il ya quand même quelques
exceptions il ya certaines personnes les
villageois ils sont tous au courant ils
savent qu'ils entendent ils parlent pas
bon vous avez c'est très important de
savoir que tout le monde ça sur place et
ça tout le monde est au courant si vous
m'élisez part de qui mais le problème
c'est comme vous et moi en tant que vous
n'avez pas compris de quoi il relève et
vous avez vous avez beau le tortionnaire
le raconte nous l'a raconté après jeu il
nous a dit voilà un jour il ya un
africain qui était en fuite c'est quand
on les appelle les africains
les bédouins les appels des africains il
est sorti on a mené à la mort dans la
mosquée où la montre est hélas les gens
ont dit non c'est pas possible ça se
passe chez non c'est pas possible nous
ont fait pas ça et donc c'est un petit
peu le même problème que pour nous en
europe aujourd'hui tant que vous voyez
pas aussi le degré de blessure vous
pouvez pas croire que ça existe je vais
peut-être laissé delphine ajouter
quelque chose sur sur cette loi du
silence
oui c'est ça c'est vrai que c'est
difficile nous de savoir on a on a passé
peu de temps dans le sinaï donc de
vraiment de se dire aux spécialistes du
tout du coin pas du tout la recontre qui
est clair c'est que c'est que sans cette
loi du silence est à dire la loi des
tribus du fait qu' on sait ce qui se
passe mais personne ne dira rien on l'a
ressenti parce que même la personne qui
nous qui les libère on sait très bien
que sa parole elle est à certains
endroits un peu verrouillé et qu'on
n'aura pas accès à exactement qui fait
quoi comment pourquoi
il ya un grand mystère quand même pour
nous mais on peut distinguer une
histoire aussi alors on l'a dit histoire
de banditisme c'est culturel ça aussi de
l'historique de la violence historique
de la violence mais aussi de religion on
peut préciser aussi que les erythréens
sont majoritairement catholique
enfin pardon chrétiens
et que peut-être aussi s'est il ya cinq
ans pour 150 % non il ya aussi des
plantations étaient 10 20 ans
aujourd'hui on peut dire qu'il ya 50 50
c'est un facteur religieux qui pousse à
la tradition les c'est vraiment un
facteur purement économique c'est un
business et pour les sites pardon pour
les 6 à 8
il y a un historique de la violence dans
le sinaï des films quand même je pense
même si effectivement c'est pas pour des
raisons religieuses
je pense quand même que c'est un
paramètre s'aggrave aggravant c'est à
dire qu'il faut quand même le justifier
donc c'est à dire que le tortionnaire
certainement il fait du lavage de
cerveau à ces petits demain on va dire
pas très certainement l'idée très
certainement pas très voilà pas très
cultivé certes les bédouins en elle et
en egypte n'ont pas de papiers
d'identité et ça c'était comme des
citoyens de seconde zone
donc il n'existe pas de fax voilà donc
c'est c'est il faut quand même
comme toujours quand même justifier un
moment donné et le fait que ce soit
quand même des chrétiens et pas des
musulmans quand même hommage en majorité
c'est un facteur effectivement
aggravante un coup une justification à
l'horreur après derrière c'est à dire
que ça participe à annuler l'autre voilà
voilà ce qu'en pensera du beau jeu sur
wii je voulais revenir sur la loi du
silence rassemblement et leur histoire
le dignitaire religieux le dit bon enfin
c'est un secret pour personne mais les
autorités sont impliqués à différents
niveaux et c'est aussi ça c'est dénoncer
ça le dire ouvertement d'ailleurs il va
pas jusqu'au bout son témoignage ou de
ce qu'il pourrait dire parce qu'à mon
avis on c'est derrière que les services
de sécurité sont impliqués y avoir des
répercussions et au soudan c'est la même
chose les services de sécurité au soudan
sont également impliqués dans le dans
ces passages la cedh enlèvement donc il
ya aussi c'est aussi une autre
composante c'est pas une structure
d'état mais l'état est quand même parti
croyante et justement alors et jean
françois dubost où ils sont entendus
quand même par des rachats ida qui est
une tribu nomade des rimes allait alors
moi j'ai un exemple moi j'ai quand même
une question parce que tout ce trafic ça
représente 600 millions de dollars
c'est l'estimation basse des estimations
basses à travers le monde
il va où cet argent ça c'est la grande
question qu'on s'est posée pendant notre
notre grande enquête bakchich a
aujourd'hui choisi m'enfin quand même
aujourd'hui on sait en fait d'abord il y
avait cette histoire de rachat en effet
et pendant longtemps on a tout mis sur
le dos de ces rachats est d'avis que
c'est une tribu nomade kiki
circulent dans le delta du nil et qui
effectivement sont des logisticiens
d'être du trafic
quel que soit le trafic depuis même
temps depuis très longtemps mais
aujourd'hui il ya les dernières comment
dire les dernières enquêtes de l'onu
montrent qu'il y a une responsabilité
pour ne pas dire une prise d'intérêt
direct de l'état major d'issaias
afeworki dans le mérite d'être humain et
ça coïncide avec un certain nombre de
témoignages concordants qui de de gens
qu'on a rencontrés qui nous racontent
tous la même chose avec des erythréens
tous les états jusque dans le sinaï a
des airs et très bien de l'eau et
rousset on peut envisager une complicité
entre les autorités égyptiennes et les
autorités érythréennes c'est à dire en
gros on va faire pratiquer de la torture
hors sol ça je ne sais pas je pourrai
pas m'avancer mais ce que je sais que
c'est que la chaîne de corruption a les
ailes et tentaculaire et subtile je sais
que dans un autre domaine le souvent les
nations-unies ont demandé au
gouvernement n est rien de ces scellés
la pression l'intimidation sur les
familles les familles à l'étranger en
fait les familles à méteren à l'étranger
donc on peut trouver un parallèle là
aussi s'ils sont capables d'aller
chercher les personnes en tout cas de
mettre une pression sur certaines
personnes réfugiées à l'étranger on peut
aisément imaginer qu'ils sont impliqués
1 degrés divers mais vous avez
aujourd'hui un rapport de l'onu qui est
tout à fait accessible et auquel on peut
avoir accès qui met en évidence la
responsabilité d'un général de la garde
rapprochée d'issaias afeworki dans
l'organisation du trafic donc dont la
tête pensante serait l'état-major daffé
war qui les bras armé de la logistique
du transport seraient les rachayda avec
l'aide de diverses personnes au soudan
l'égypte est le bras armé de la torture
sera donc les bédouins de la tribu de
savoir alors on va arriver sur la
communauté internationale les etats-unis
accusent l'erythrée de soutenir al
shabab le mouvement islamiste somalien
rallié à al qaïda qu'en est il jean
françois dubost
n'en a pas on n'a pas nous forcément
d'information pour pour crédibiliser cet
aspect là ou pas en fait on est plutôt
sur le volet aujourd'hui ce phénomène là
est relié à un réseau terroriste quels
qu'ils soient
personne n'a réussi à le mettre en
évidence trouvé ces choses là
c'est sur la piste de l'argent mais par
rapport aux va l'argent c'est ça la
question fait c'est vrai que à chaque
qu'on a posés là c'est jacques ça aux
états unis pourquoi les états unis avant
cet argument là parce que c'est vrai que
les groupuscules en tout cas du sinaï
sont sont apparus au même moment mais je
pense que la corrélation un peut pas non
plus faire aussi rapidement parce que
c'est juste à réparer en 2009 là où
l'egypte étant chaos
c'est à dire avec la révolution donc les
deux les documents ça c'est la bonne
piste
toutes les bédouins partout dans le
monde et on peut faire le parallèle avec
ce qui s'est passé au mali profite
d'état réellement affaibli et du chaos
pour jouer leur carte
ceci dit un clair soutien du régime
érythréen ou aux milices somaliennes
ça ça fait aussi partie des rappels a
fait en dix ans et celle d entraîner
militairement et de leur offrir un
refuge eu le temps de les entraîner donc
il ya déjà un lien matériel et
militaires alors la piraterie en somalie
par exemple
c'est dire ici non mais en tout cas la
fourniture d'armes à gaza ou en syrie ça
c'est clairement lié après le maillon
qui manquent
oui puisque le trafic le passe par les
tunnels de gaza et par la bordure
jusqu'à ce qu'ils aient les grands
barbelés construit par israël puisqu'il
sera elle s'est défendue sur ses
frontières en tout cas c'est la nouvelle
politique on va dire en construisant 240
kilomètres de barbelés entrer l'un des
gaz a donc
vous aviez quand même un lien direct
entre les tribus bédouines du nord-sinaï
et le passage de cm2 faite de ces
éléments
donc de là à dire que ils se sont
diversifiées il n'y a qu'un pas dont on
attend d'avoir les preuves pour le
franchir alors en cinq ans on parle de
50000 personnes
sous-estimer un obama où ces trois ans
est très difficile à évaluer
enlevée torturée et on n'en parle pas on
n'en parlera pas on n'en parle pas parce
que les erythréens sont leurs premières
et demi j'ai envie c'est à dire un petit
peu parlé quand même oui et un email
mais la veyron d'ailleurs incroyable et
auquel ego parlement européen raconté il
ya eu déjà des choses qu'on aime qui ont
été dites mais c'est vrai que ça n'a
jamais intéressé ça m'a permis noté
internationale n'intervient pas ayrault
jean françois dubost bonnes questions
sur ce sujet comme sur un autre pourquoi
effectivement je vois là j'ai pas la
réponse c'est ce qui est certain c'est
qu'elle pourrait intervenir avant ou
après notamment avant je prends soin
réfugiés qui sont dans les camps il ya
des solutions de l'est de réinstallation
dans d'autres états du monde
aujourd'hui en 2012 et enfin en tout cas
en 2012 1800 seul 1800 réfugiés
érythréens étaient sortis de ces camps
pour être installées dans des lieux sûrs
alors il le faire plus fréquemment pour
un plus grand nombre c'est aussi éviter
de prendre des routes dangereuses comme
celle là et c'est aussi qu'on retrouve à
lampedusa et c'est également heureux
qu'on retrouve en libye qui acculé songé
de prendre la mer qui traversent la mer
ce qui sont qui sinon il faut aussi
préciser que ces maisons de torture
parce que comme maintenant en israël ne
peuvent plus accéder de tera c'est en
libye ces temps-ci match aller mais
voilà les maisons de torture ont fait
des petits voilà c'est quand même un
système qui a fait ses preuves
on a vu que sa levée d'un des fonds
incroyable et donc ça s'est propagé au
soudan à la libye et au yémen et je
voudrais ajouter une chose par rapport à
la question des erythréens et pourquoi
on n'en parle pas les erythréens sont
dans un système dont ils savent qu'ils
sont persécutés
ils ont donc pendant très longtemps pas
témoigné pas osé témoigner de leurs
propres blessures et on rentre
maintenant dans une dans un moment
historique où ils disent on parler sic
ou terme en écouter pour les fêtes c'est
bien nous et où on en a parlé quand même
j'ai lu la presse
il ya eu des actifs dans le point dans
l'express
et de toute la presse en a parlé même le
grand journal a fait un petit reportage
complètement erronées sur les réfugiés
érythréens en disant qu' un jeune
erythréen disait qu'il était persécuté
en erythrée parce qu'il était chrétien
ce qui est inconcevable
donc non on en parle quand même un petit
peu mais pas autant qu'on devrait en
parler
est ce que par exemple le fait que la
mer rouge soit une voix cruciales des
échanges commerciaux internationaux
c'est une raisons éventuelles vous
attendiez à ce que la communauté
internationale se retiennent
d'intervenir parce que si on perturbe
que cette zone là ça peut perturber les
échanges ça peut perturber le tente
d'anciens qui est déjà fragile
aujourd'hui c'est difficile comment
voulez vous qu elle c'est une question
si une conjecture je pense que c'est
très compliqué que la communauté
internationale est l'anti leur foi
sauvant plusieurs années avant de bouger
la preuve on aime ce qui est
démocratique et tout ce qui tout ce qui
se fait dans la paix est beaucoup plus
lent que ce qui se fait dans la violence
j'en ai trouvé impliqué sur tout mais
c'est ça c'est rapide je dirais que le
raisonnement inverse qui est fait si on
prend le cas de l'union européenne et
face à ces arrivées de d'erythréens qui
sont comme la deuxième nationalité à
arriver mais qui sont hautement protégé
en europe le le pari fait par l'union
européenne c'est de dire on va
stabiliser ces populations réfugiées
dans les pays justement concernés c'est
à dire egypte lybie potentiellement mais
ça c'est du long terme c'est du très
long terme si jamais ça arrive un jour
donc si les personnes les dirigeants
sont dans cette logique là de dire non
il vaut mieux les mettre là pour éviter
qu'ils traversent la méditerranée c'est
sûr qu'en même temps on va pas forcément
intervenir directement pour mettre fin à
ce type de trafic puisque nous dans une
autre logique tel site delphine deloget
pourquoi ils sont en suède s'est réfugié
aujourd'hui la suède a été plutôt bon
élève un petit peu de l'union européenne
pour l'accueil des migrants et les
effets déjà l'une des premières raisons
la deuxième c'est que historiquement il
ya quand même beaucoup des rites rien
n'abat il ya une forte communauté je ne
connais pas les chiffres
peut-être enfin fabien déconner mais
donc voilà donc c'est forcément une
communauté qui
kb qui voit là il y en a beaucoup à
londres et en suède c'est vrai que
traditionnellement ce sont c'est un pays
qui accueille serait bien les réfugiés
de moins en moins comme le fait en
france en france par exemple est ce
qu'elle est la communauté le gagne
communautaire et rennes ou et oui il ya
de plus en plus des retraites et
demandent l'asile et c'est la question
que je que je posais amnesty
international c'est que les trois-quarts
l'ofpra qui décide des demandes des
demandes d'asile refusent en général les
déserteurs donc il part du principe qu'à
partir du moment où on a déserté l'armée
de son pays on ne relève pas directement
de la convention de genève
et justement je posais la question et je
pense que et que vous connaissez très
bien la réponse n'est ce pas salement
blessé il ya 300 demandes d'asile des
vitréens à sur l'année écoulée
vous avez jusque 14 pour cent personnes
qui sont protégés leur après il faut
prendre en compte l'appel ils font appel
et à ce moment là il ya beaucoup plus de
protection donc pour environ 300
personnes vous avez 180 personnes qui
sont protégés mais majoritairement par
l'instance d'appel est pas tout de suite
par le frein est effectivement les les
causes sont multiples mais on les
suspecte souvent loft protocole est
suspecte souvent ne pas être érythréens
ou ne pas avoir subi de ce qu'ils
invoquent alors que la situation dans ce
pays il est ce soir il nous reste il
nous reste juste deux minutes
c'est ce documentaire c'est c'était une
piste pour vous une enquête et puis
aujourd'hui c'est une vraie cause c'est
quoi la prochaine étape pour vous parce
que j'allais m'en rester là
non c'est la piste de l'argent en partie
c'est de comprendre comment est ce qu'on
peut construire un système avec les
intermédiaires partout en europe mais
c'est surtout de comprendre comment est
ce que on arrive au stade où on fait on
laisse exister une antichambre de la
torture sur l'autre rive de la
méditerranée
parce que ce système est en train de se
propager et si ça continue comme ça tous
les gens qui vont arriver en europe
auront traversé des souffrances
absolument innommable avant d'arriver
chez nous ce qui pose un problème sur
des générations et des générations
voilà le défi de la dgi a parlé beaucoup
en fait des familles qui sont en europe
et une idée aussi d
enfin des solutions pour comprendre un
peu tout ça c'est on a cherché beaucoup
l ont pas voulu témoigner on sait qu'on
a à rennes c'est qu'il y en a pour les
mêmes raisons qu'on a évoqué sa peur du
gouvernement elles ont parfois perdu
d'un proche
ça leur fait peur alors que peut-être
une des premières choses c'est même déjà
de porter plainte parce que c'est des
gens qui vivent peut-être en france à
londres en suède en tout cas en europe
et qui ont été rançonné c'est à dire
c'est des gens qui ont cotisé ici pour
gagner de l'argent ici donc c'est bien
de l'argent européen qui part du père
noël
on est arrivé au terme de ce débat merci
à tous je vous souhaite beaucoup de
courage et bonne chance dans votre
combat
merci d'être venu sur ce plateau si
cette question vous intéresse vous
conseille le livre de fabienne loureiro
ethiopie erythrée frères ennemis de la
corne de l'afrique le voici voilà la
semaine prochaine vous retrouver bien
sûr laurent bazin pour un documentaire
sur les avocats des étrangers quant à
moi je vous donne rendez vous dans trois
semaines pour un documentaire en deux
parties intitulé asiatiques de france a
très vite sur public sénat